[Music]
all right today's question comes from
abby in north dakota abby writes
my husband and i are 32 years old and we
have a home worth 400 000
the mortgage is 900 bucks a month with
nine years remaining
my husband has epilepsy and has been
unable to work for two years i bought
the property and have been the sole
breadwinner during our marriage he's
worked on and off at so many jobs i've
lost count i would like to start a
family soon but he wants to sell
everything and live in a van for four
years i wonder if he wants to go down by
the river
i don't want to start over from zero and
it seems easy for him to throw
everything away when he's not the one
who worked for it
he says he does not want to die having
never had the chance to travel but that
he won't do it without me
do i sell at all and lose my dream of a
stable home or do i tell him no and live
under the weight of his disappointment
oh my gosh yes
yeah i'd be in a stable home and living
under the weight of my husband's
disappointment
that's
the most racial thing i've heard yeah
you can just go be disappointed husband
i'm living in my life i will i will take
the emotional toll and have a roof yes
and not a fan no and again people live
this life this is the thing people go
and get school buses and they and they
retro i mean a lot of youtubes they they
do it and it's the thing that they love
to do and i think if both of you if that
was the thing you love to do and you're
like you know what we're going to just
travel the country in our van and our
bus and live the life
work yeah let me
find some wi-fi and you can work and
take your computer it'll be great but if
it's not both of your dreams it turns
into a disaster yes okay i want to work
through this backwards anytime you're in
a marriage
and you back yourself into a corner and
you create an either or situation
outside of an abusive situation either i
stay abused or i leave the abuse right
that's an either or
short of that
do i sell it all and lose my dream or do
i crush my husband who's dying of
epilepsy
there's you've you've painted yourself
in a corner where it's either a grenade
or a nuclear bomb and i gotta pick one
because one of us is blown up it is yeah
this is the only two options in the
entire world josh that's it so
always and this goes for anybody who's
in a relationship with anybody for
anything do i have to stay and be
miserable forever or do i quit this job
and then go be home
let's try a third option or maybe a
fourth let's look for them right so
don't back yourself into a corner here
there's other options here the second
thing is
you all have not as a couple dealt with
epilepsy and what that means you have a
world abby that you have and you've
created that you want your marriage to
look like you want your home to look
like you have a picture of a family in
your house
and you have a husband with a
debilitating neurological condition
on the other side he has a picture of
his life where he feels like he's dying
and i don't she doesn't i can't tell if
he's if this is terminal or what but
let's assume that it's not
he's created a picture of living in a
van down by the river and he like let's
just let's sell it all let's go get it
what happens when you both have you both
had different pictures of what your life
is going to look like you start using
language like yours and mine in his
and mine and i did this and he didn't do
that
and all of a sudden you are
you know you're sharing a bed with
somebody and you're a foot apart from
them but you're 5 000 miles away from
each other right you're way on the other
side of the world this is not a finance
conversation this is not a do we live in
a van or a house conversation
this is coming to terms with this is our
marriage and this is what our life is
and
when we recognize what it is then we can
decide what this marriage could become
together right abby you have to decide
if you want to be married to a man with
epilepsy who is unable to work
point blank and he has to decide if he's
going to continue to be married to you
and
your money is y'all's money and y'all's
home is y'all's home right all of this
stuff is we're doing this together yep
right and that's the big picture and
then you know tactically as you live
life out like what are ways to kind of
scratch that edge of him wanting to
travel do you go get an rv and go for a
week like like there are still those
those options in between multiple
options doesn't mean that you can never
ever ever travel or it mean you could
never ever have kids like it's you guys
there's a medium ground here to get to
lots of median of roads in the middle of
that yes on the tactical side as well so
good